se nos pide graficar la función f x es
igual a menos 3x cuadrada más 8 vamos a
hacer esto tomando diversos valores de x
encontraremos los valores de fx
correspondientes para posteriormente
graficar los pero la primera pregunta
que tengo para ti es simplemente al ver
la definición de fx puedes deducir qué
tipo de gráfica se verá será una recta
será una parábola será una
circunferencia no se podría ser algo
bizarro y extraño que nunca hayas visto
antes debería quedar claro que esto va a
ser una parábola la función está
definida como menos 13 x 8 aquí tenemos
el término menos 3x cuadrada que es un
término cuadrática no tenemos aquí un
término cúbico un término la cuarta que
pudiera sugerir una gráfica bizarra esto
es claramente una parábola ahora lo que
podemos preguntarnos es la parábola va a
abrir hacia arriba o la parábola abrir
hacia abajo y viendo la forma de la
función podemos tener la intuición de si
abre hacia arriba o abre hacia abajo si
vemos el coeficiente del término
cuadrática menos 3 que tenemos aquí
eso nos va a indicar que la palabra la
va a abrir hacia abajo va a abrir hacia
abajo entonces con la intuición que ya
tenemos ahora de que es una parábola y
que va a abrir hacia abajo vamos a
graficar la así que déjame hacer unos
ejes por acá este de aquí es nuestro eje
x nuestro eje x y este de acá este eje
vertical este eje vertical es nuestro
eje y nuestro eje y voy a hacer por acá
entonces una tabla donde voy a encontrar
los valores de fx construyamos la tabla
en esta primera columna tendremos los
valores de x y en esta segunda columna
los valores de fx posteriormente los
graficar hemos voy a calcular primero
todos estos valores para que tenga una
idea acerca de cuál es la escala
adecuada para los ejes voy a tomar
diversos valores de x empecemos con x
igual a menos 2 entonces cuando x es
igual a menos 2 estoy eligiendo números
que nos faciliten los cálculos
cuando x es igual a menos 2 f x es igual
a menos 3 x menos 2 al cuadrado
+ + 8 y esto es igual a menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 4 positivo x menos 34 x
menos 3 es menos 12 + 8 es igual a menos
4 veamos qué pasa cuando x es igual a
menos 1 que obtenemos entonces para fx
que obtenemos entonces para fx bueno fx
va a ser igual a menos 3 que multiplica
a menos 1 al cuadrado más 8 y esto que
es igual menos 1 al cuadrado es igual a
1 x menos 3 es igual a menos 3 más 8
esto es igual a 5 evaluamos ahora f x
cuando x es igual a 0
esto es muy fácil de evaluar cuando x es
igual a 0 fx es igual a menos 3 x 0 al
cuadrado esto lo puede escribir de
cualquier manera así o también puede
escribirlo de esta otra manera
- 3 x 0 al cuadrado más 8 este término
se anula se hace 0 y esto es igual a 8
veamos ahora qué pasa cuando x es igual
a 1 evaluamos la función en uno
obtenemos entonces que es igual a menos
3 por 1 al cuadrado más 81 al cuadrado
es 1 por menos 3 es igual a menos tres
más 8 esto es igual a 5 finalmente que
obtenemos cuando x es igual a 2 cuánto
vale
fx cuando x es igual a 2 o
equivalentemente cuánto es
efe de 2 evaluamos menos 3 por 2 al
cuadrado más 82 al cuadrado es 4 por
menos 3 menos 12 + 8 esto es igual a
menos 4 graphic hemos estos puntos
entonces entonces los valores de x que
elegí van de menos 2 a 2 hagamos nuestra
escala menos 2 - 1
y 2 y los valores de fx que encontramos
es nuestro eje que estamos graficando de
hecho de igual a fx los valores de fx de
acuerdo a la tabla que encontramos son
valores que se ubican entre menos 4 y
más 8
establezcamos entonces nuestra escala
aquí tenemos más 8
este sería entonces más 4 ya que
quedaría entonces menos 4 si éste es 4
positivo este de acá es 6
luego aquí tenemos 57 sería 23 y esté
aquí 1 graphic hemos entonces estos
puntos que tenemos aquí cuando x es
igual a menos 12 f x es igual a menos 4
de hecho lo que estamos graficando es
igual a fx estoy graficando sobre el eje
fx la gráfica de igual a esta función
graphic hemos entonces el punto menos 2
menos 4 eso nos lleva a x igual a menos
2 y igual a menos 4 aquí lo tenemos
luego tenemos el punto menos 15 menos 15
lo tenemos aquí estamos graficando igual
a fx no lo olvidemos menos 1,5
posteriormente tenemos el punto 0,8
encontramos efe de 0 igual a 8 lo voy a
poner aquí estamos graficando ye igual a
fx que en este caso es el punto 0,8
ubicamos aquí 0,8 posteriormente
15.15 ahí y finalmente tenemos el punto
2 como a menos 4 el punto 2 coma menos 4
ahí lo tenemos y ahora ya podemos
conectar los puntos sabemos que va a ser
una parábola voy a hacerle en azul la
voz de una línea entrecortada que es
mucho más fácil la parábola viene por
acá
aquí tenemos la parábola y se extiende
indefinidamente hacia los lados ahora ya
voy a trazar la línea sólida una
parábola que viene hacia abajo como lo
habíamos visto ya cómo lo habíamos
intuido previamente a partir de revisar
el término cuadrática pudimos establecer
que este es una parábola que ve hacia
abajo como ahora hemos comprobado con su
gráfica